actually believe that uh outside of like
hardcore finance use cases
um we're going to see chrome os actually
get to the point where more people are
using it
um and i think it's sort of like a
hidden uh
gem that most people don't actually pay
attention to it's infecting schools
because
in a school you log in with your google
account whether it's google docs or
gmail
and your entire desktop just shows up
all your br all your
bookmarks everything your cloud
everything is just there
then you log out if you're logged in as
a guest
and it's gone yep so the idea that you
have a computer with a desktop and you
left something on your desktop and you
have to go home to get it
but you got to remote into your desktop
goes away as a concept which is
incredible
or if you have one computer there so we
have one computer in the house that's
shared
like in the domestic office and
everybody uses it so you go to log in
and it's got everybody's little icon on
the bottom you log in boom and you're up
and running well the other thing i think
people ignore about chrome os and
chromebook is that
they've gone through this like very
complex provisioning processes for
school
right if you think about kids whose
laptops like they get damaged all this
kind of
crazy stuff happens to it yeah if you
can handle that scenario
you can handle the enterprise scenario
and also for sure chrome os is way more
secure than a lot of other systems
right um because it's all sandbox in the
browser and so i actually think there's
could be an incredible enterprise
enterprise play there in the future and
so i i'm keep watching for google do
that i mean they haven't done it yet but
and how does figma work in chrome just
perfectly flawlessly
and that's one of the things that people
say why they don't go to chrome where
they don't give up their
ridiculously priced mac computers is
because they're tied to the adobe suite
yep
are you seeing people leaving the adobe
suite and moving to figma yeah we're
seeing people
leave lots of different platforms
whether it's adobe or you know their
computing platform of choice to adopt a
cheaper computer
uh we're seeing like our vision for
figma is to make design accessible to
everybody
and that's a really key component of it
is to make it so that regardless of
where you're coming from
you can use figma wherever you are